ich habe hier ja für die bundesregierung
vielfach betont friedliche
demonstrationen sind auch in zeiten der
pandemie wichtig meinungen müssen
öffentlich vertreten werden können
kritik soll und muss in einer demokratie
auch immer möglich sein
in leipzig wurde nun die
versammlungsfreiheit zum teil gezielt
ausgenutzt auflagen der
versammlungsbehörde wurden von vielen
teilnehmern und teilnehmerinnen nicht
ernst genommen und am ende haben
extremisten chaoten gewaltbereite
menschen sich nach der auflösung der
versammlung dann ihren weg durch leipzig
bereitet das ist in dieser äußerst
kritischen phase der pandemie in der wir
als land alle zusammen stecken ein
fatales signal
dazu kommt dass es eben auch berichte
gibt wonach während der demonstration
und auch nach der demonstration
journalisten und journalistinnen
körperlich attackiert wurden es wurden
auch sicherheitskräfte und polizisten
und polizistinnen angegriffen
gewalttätige auseinandersetzungen und
der missbrauch des demonstrationsrechts
sind nicht zulässig
es ist für gewalt und für provokation
kein platz und ebensowenig bis platz für
extremistisches gedankengut oder für
verschwörungs mieten egal von welcher
seite
diese kommen die versammlungsfreiheit
ist eines der höchsten güter unserer
verfassung zweifelsohne die
entscheidungen der versammlungsbehörde
auch die auflagen einer
versammlungsbehörde müssen eingehalten
und gewährleistet werden wie es der
bundesinnenminister vorher schon gesagt
hat und jetzt vielleicht gebe ich dann
an den kollegen
ja wir beobachten ja dieses
demonstrationsgeschehen schon seit
einigen monaten ist seitdem ist die
pandemie gibt gibt es auch proteste
diese proteste verändern sich natürlich
im laufe der zeit
wir sehen insbesondere am vergangenen
wochenende dass sehr viele menschen sich
mobilisieren und diesen aufrufen folgen
es bleibt aber bei der grundsätzlichen
einschätzung dass wir es bei den
demonstrationsteilnehmern
eine sehr heterogen zusammengesetzte
gruppe von menschen dass es sich um eine
sehr heterogene gruppe handelt die
sicherheitsbehörden wissen auch schon
seit längerem dass extremisten
insbesondere rechtsextremisten reichs
bürger versuchen sich diese proteste
ihre zwecke zu eigen zu machen oder sie
für ihre zwecke zu instrumentalisieren
nach wie vor bleiben die
sicherheitsbehörden aber bei der
auffassung dass es noch nicht gelungen
ist dass extremisten die zunehmend
offener in erscheinung treten und auch
sichtbar werden die proteste vollständig
für ihre zwecke instrumentalisieren
konnten also es bleibt dabei wir haben
es mit einer sehr heterogenen
zusammensetzung zu tun
nachfragen angenommen sie hätten auch
die verschärfungen oder die zunehmende
aktivität da würde mich interessieren
wie bewerten sie vor diesem hintergrund
denn dann die verläufe in leipzig bei
denen die polizei nicht die
demonstration aufgelöst hat und auch
nicht eingeschritten ist oder zumindest
denen auch den gewalt fallen eskalation
nicht herr werden konnte
naja also zunächst einmal hat ja herr
seibert gerate das notwendige gesagt
gewalt ist bei der ausübung des
versammlungsrechts kein zulässiges
mittel und wird auch nicht akzeptiert
ich habe eben angedeutet dass wir bei
der zusammensetzung der gruppen durchaus
erkennen dass in letzter zeit die anzahl
derer die auch gewaltbereit sind zunimmt
das ist auch in leipzig offensichtlich
gewesen aber deswegen ist es noch längst
nicht legitim und die
sicherheitsbehörden sehen sich eben dann
mit konkreten situationen konfrontiert
mit denen sie umgehen müssen und in
leipzig haben wir die situation ja
erlebt dass eine veranstaltung in dieser
größenordnung von den
versammlungsbehörden zunächst nicht
genehmigt wurde aber dann durch eine
gerichtliche entscheidung doch stattfand
und die polizei sah sich am samstagabend
mit der situation konfrontiert dass also
mehr als 20.000 menschen in der
innenstadt von leipzig zusammen gekommen
sind und protestiert haben und dann ist
es für die polizei eine abwägung wie sie
damit umgeht
und nach allem was wir wissen und was
auch der bundesinnenminister gestern mit
seinem kollegen in sachsen gesprochen
hat hat sich die polizei dafür
entschieden mit blick auf die heterogene
zusammensetzung der gruppe auch mit
blick auf die größe der gruppe eine
strategie der deeskalation zu fahren das
war sozusagen die grundentscheidung die
die polizei getroffen hat der
innenminister von sachsen hat das auch
öffentlich schon klar gemacht es war die
entscheidung gegen eine personengruppe
die überwiegend friedlich ist aus der es
auch gewalt heraus gab aber die in ihrer
gesamtheit überwiegend friedlich ist
eben nicht mit polizeilicher gewalt
vorzugehen sondern den versuch zu
unternehmen
dieses geschehen möglichst friedlich zu
ende zu bringen das war die überzeugung
der polizei die findet der
bundesinnenminister
richtig gute sommer verschiedene länder
fragen dazu fangen bei ihnen angehen
dann die mittel kommen zu ihnen dann
noch mal sind sie drin war es hermann
von der süddeutschen erleichtert dazu
direkt der nachfrage also ist klar die
diese demos sind sache der
länderpolizeien aber wie gedenkt denn
die bundesregierung diese zunehmend
[Musik]
radikal werden den kundgebungen zu
schützen auch die dort beteiligten
journalisten die presse und welches
signal sollte die sicherheitskräfte bei
diesem thema bundesweit aussenden ja ich
glaube zunächst einmal bevor wir uns
auch den radikalen kräften in dieser
gruppen zusammensetzung widmen muss man
auch noch einmal deutlich machen
das ist das größte problem was wir am
vergangenen wochenende gesehen haben
doch darin besteht dass mehr als 20.000
menschen zusammengekommen sind und sich
nicht an die auflagen der
versammlungsbehörde gehalten haben man
könnte auch sagen die infektions
schutzmaßnahmen missachtet haben und das
ist etwas das es ein verhalten dass es
unverantwortlich und scharf zu
kritisieren herr seibert hat das eben
deutlich gemacht und es ist deswegen
scharf zu kritisieren weil diese
menschen nicht nur für sich selbst
handeln also nicht nur für diese gruppe
die da aus freien stücken zusammen kommt
sondern sie nimmt mit diesem verhalten
ja die gesamte gesellschaft in
mithaftung denn wenn es zu einem dadurch
gesteigerten infektionsgeschehen kommt
hat das auswirkungen auf die
medizinische kapazität in deutschland
und deswegen ist eine solche situation
nicht zu akzeptieren denn sie betrifft
auch personen die eine solche
zusammenkunft nicht gesucht haben und
sich vorbildlich an die infektionsschutz
maßnahmen der bundesregierung und der
länder gehalten haben
innerhalb dieser gruppe kam es dann zu
ausschreitungen ich kann nur noch mal
wiederholen dass die polizei sich immer
auch fragen muss mit welchem agieren mit
welchen aktionen tritt welche
lageentwicklung 1 und bei
veranstaltungen dieser größenordnung
ist es häufig so dass die polizei die
strategie der deeskalation sucht und
dann auch umsetzt in der hoffnung dass
sich die situation der ja zum teil
ungeordnet war nicht noch verschärft und
noch mehr unordnung und chaos entsteht
sondern dass man das möglichst friedlich
und geordnet zu ende bringen kann in dem
bewusstsein dass die auflagen ja schon
von beginn an nicht eingehalten wurden
man muss glaube ich auch deutlich sagen
dass die polizei eine veranstaltung die
so stattfindet und so genehmigt wurde
auch nur noch bedingt korrigieren kann
der bundesinnenminister hat ja schon
gestern deutlich gemacht dass alle
beteiligten behörden auch die gerichte
ein im moment in dieser
ausnahmesituation eine sehr
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe haben und
entscheidungen zu treffen müssen dass
sie auch realistisch umsetzbar sind und
das kann man zumindest wenn man
rückblickend auf das geschehen in
leipzig schaut kann man zumindest den
eindruck bekommen dass wir das künftig
besser machen müssen
wir sind bild und wie ihr liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren